oh scheiße was ist denn jetzt passiert
etwas geht abwärts willkommen bei neuen
video ich bin eigentlich gerade
überhaupt nicht mehr motiviert das zum
dritten mal aufzunehmen weil
ursprünglich okay wir fangen erst mal
ganz von vorne an
ich habe mich dieses mal ein bisschen
von den youtube trends deutschland
inspirieren lassen es kam natürlich mal
wieder aus amerika aber irgendwie kommt
ihr dann auch alles nach deutschland auf
jeden fall hatte ich ursprünglich vor
ein video zu machen indem ich das größte
kinder der welt mache weil ich kinder
durch einfach so krass liebe und da
hätte ich also voll hinter gestanden ich
hätte voll bock drauf gehabt das ding
war nur ich bin losgefahren wollte
kinder joyce kaufen kinder gibt es
allerdings nur im sommer warum weiß kein
mensch
aber was soll ich mache ich war wirklich
bestimmt 20 unterwegs waren fünf
verschiedenen geschäften zehn
verschiedenen tankstellen
das war übertrieben aber nirgendwo gibt
es kinder joyce und dann stand ich in
einem großhandels discounter ich will
jetzt den namen auch lidl gar nicht
sagen und drehte mich um und sah ganz
viele mauer haben und dass wir die idee
kommen es findest du auch geld macht
doch einfach das größte mann der welt so
also muss sich deshalb zum zweiten mal
aufnehmen weil ich halt einmal gesagt
hab ich will kinder durchs machen
dann habe ich gesagt ich will mal angst
machen dann wollte ich jetzt gerade es
wieder schneien und mir ist aufgefallen
ich hatte keinen ton also ich hab halt
ohne ton aufgenommen
super alex ganz stark jetzt sage ich
eigentlich das gleiche zum dritten mal
aber wen interessiert ich würde sagen
wir fangen sofort an jetzt erst mal wie
ich einkaufen waren ein bisschen und
schreibt doch einfach mal und in die
kommentare aus welchem produkt ich hoffe
das größte der welt machen soll
eigentlich habe ich das nicht vor aber
wenn wirklich was krasses dabei ist wo
ihr alle daumen nach oben da last weil
das wirklich krass ist und auch voll
kreativ so sei kreativ trotzdem
kommentare dann mache ich das vielleicht
noch mal aber jetzt erstmal viel spaß
mit diesem video ps fans gefällt das den
dom nach oben
so leute wie ging es los die kinder das
kauf ich hab noch mein bruder dabei ich
muss ja noch was essen erstmalig habe
noch nicht viel gegessen heute und ich
wollte nur schnell was sagen und zwar
hat er
und zwar ein guter freund von mir ja nix
sein neues lied rausgebracht der link
ist dazu einfach mal wieder beschreibung
der erst mal kurz rein menschlich
gefällt dann checkt das auf jeden fall
mal ab
sie scheint wieder 1 in front
ja
hahn hatte sich das nun
twitter mit
kennedy
hey leute eigentlich wollte ich ja das
größte kinder der welt machen
aber wir haben jetzt in so vielen läden
und irgendwie gibt es nirgendwo deswegen
problem ist jetzt einmal noch bei der
tankstelle
aber wenn gestern nicht haben weil ich
jetzt schon verlegt dann hab ich grad
schon mehr kommen dann machst du einfach
das größte mann der welt weil man
schmeckt auch gut vor allem die roten
ein paar sekunden später leute es gibt
einfach nirgendwo kinder die gibt es
wohl nur im sommer wusste ich auch nicht
auf jeden fall fahren wir jetzt wieder
zurück und kaufen noch schnell mauer
das ist zwar nicht so geil wie kinder
dabei auf geld und machen daraus einfach
das größte mann der welt
also ich hab mir extra noch so eine
backform jetzt gekauft wie fünf euro
oder so damit ich diese 5
das sind auf jeden fall jetzt drei oder
vier nahtlos und die pfiffige kapuzen
und jetzt fahren wir erst mal nach hause
zwei stunden fertig sein
leute ich bin jetzt mittlerweile unten
wir haben jetzt ungefähr 43 in der nacht
meine ich ungefähr seit 12 uhr hier dran
sitzen und diese mauer muss hier raus
bastl aus ihren hessischen verpackung
und ich bin jetzt auch nicht fertig aber
ich würde mal sagen so zehn minuten
dauert es noch auf jeden fall was so
ultra lang gedauert aber es sieht doch
mega geil aus und es riecht auch
ziemlich lecker ich will gar nicht lange
lagern wir machen einfach weiter
es ist einfach so heftig schneite waren
und ich weiß gar nicht warum ich habe
einfach keinen bock mehr
ehrlich das ist so eine scheiße arbeite
ich ja irgendwie noch zehn freunde
anrufen sollen
dann werden wir jetzt wahrscheinlich
schon fertig aber ich bin zugleich auf
schulter gespannt wie das gleich wieder
da
ich glaub's nicht wehren uns ja immer
sofort geschafft ich noch zwölf stück
fünf stück von 302 vergessen
338 so webel für den letzten warmen
kohler komm schon hier wirklich geweint
leute gebt euch einfach mal das hier
geil oder es lag einfach mal einer
darunter dann werde ich mal sagen ab in
die küche
ich bin so müde hier haben wir einmal
einen top ich bin mir gerade irgendwie
voll unsicher wie ich das machen soll
ich würde sagen ich nehme es einfach
erstmal diesen topf macht ein bisschen
wasser reinigt ein bisschen bis es dann
kocht also ständig an mir auf dem herd
und dann kommen die mauer ums rein
ich glaube dass musste klappte so das
ganze ist hier auf stufe 12 ich tue aus
spaß jetzt erst mal einfach so ein paar
ein mal gucken was mit denen passiert
lässt sich auf eine guck mal so weiter
es kocht ich würde sagen es ist an der
zeit dass geeignet man bisher nach köln
wo es ja voll eis
vielleicht sollte ernsthaft ein bisschen
wasser rein tun
jetzt nehmen wir einfach mal so ein
kochlöffel alter jetzt wo wir so ich
würde sagen dass master hat sich
eigentlich aufgelöst
die frage ist jetzt nur müssen wir noch
abwarten bis sich das wieder
einigermaßen zusammensetzt oder was
mache ich jetzt am besten
sonst würde ich jetzt einfach erst mal
das wasser hier raus abgelassen und das
dann in dieser box tun was passiert hier
gerade so ist gut
also leute das hier ist jetzt gerade der
topf der sieht eigentlich ganz lecker
aus so leute das war jetzt die ganze
kühlschrank und das ist jetzt eigentlich
wirklich fest geworden
ich weiß nicht so das problem ist schon
und runter ist jetzt ich denke mal
geschmolzener zucker dass ich weiß nicht
ob das karamell ist oder so aber könnte
sein vielleicht ist es ja jetzt keiner
mehr gewonnen ich kann mich da jetzt
nicht so aus ich würde sagen da ist uns
noch mit kamera ich würde sagen ich
versuche das jetzt einfach mal
abzuschneiden
du hast es nun jetzt passiert voll krass
oder
ok soll ich mal rein weißen alter es bis
hier hin dass du wichtig dass merck nach
cola erdberg kirsch orange zitrone okay
leute ein bismarck ich noch kann man das
verformt sich voll
meine finger die sind so klebrig ich
weiß ich hab ich das vielleicht
abwaschen kann
also ich finde die ford wolle man hat
oder ob er es probiert immer es ist
schon fest wir kommen jetzt ein teich
kriegs und hoch du müsstest messer dann
aber sehr vorsichtig jetzt zieht das
hoch und schmeckt heuer steht ohne
scheiß sie so note von 1 10 10 10 war
wie gut kochen können einmal noch
überreicht
das ganze auch also beben ums leben
das echt so klebe ich nur schreibt man
die kommentare was ist dieses sieht halt
aus wie karamell aber ist irgendwie
nicht karamell oder das nicht schmeckt
genauso wie dieses mal keine ahnung dass
es ist ja heute das war's mit diesem
video wenn es euch gefallen hat dann
lässt man doch nach oben da und ich habe
es am anfang schon gesagt schreibt an
die kommentare von welchem produkt man
noch das größte der welt machen kann
also eigentlich das nicht vor aber wenn
man es richtig cool ist dabei sind
überlegt mir zu machen schreibt die
kommentare
lasst uns nach oben da sektor 1 nicht ab
und ansonsten würde ich sagen wir sehen
uns morgen 19 uhr bei höheren video
hotlines und schaut euch das mal an